Good morning Hank it's Monday
I'm a man, I'm a zebra I'm a...  man bra
Oh wait that's something else
So Hank I'm here in the great city of Chicago
at a very crowded English teachers' conference
which is a lot of fun because
A. I get to talk with English teachers about books; one of my favourite endeavours and
B. I was starting to miss signing my name
But before that, and before the man bra
and before a bath so luxurious and wasteful that it made me wonder whether luxurious and wasteful are synonyms
and before we were coming up the elevator with Henry battling the oppression of strollers
and before I found myself at the bean
and before I ate a breakfast at a restaurant
where the hostess was a nerdfighter
and before I was reminded of the many and very miseries of Chicago traffic
before all that I was at Brilliance Audio, my audio book publisher
narrating The Fault In Our Stars
So there will be 2 audiobook versions:
one real audiobook narrated by Kate Rudd
pictured here
greeting her adoring public in a Panera
and one narrated by me
Kate sounds exactly like Hazel
and her recording is brilliant
I sound like a thirty four year old man making for some awkward moments
here's a sample: "Chapter 6"
Actually no, we must avoid all spoilers
my recording will be available only in a physical, limited edition boxset available at dtfba.com
Kate's recording will be the real audiobook and available everywhere
the reason it's possible to have 2 audiobooks
one released by dftba records
and one released by Brilliance
is that they worked with me to share the audio publishing rights in a really cool and innovative way
and when copyright law works, that's how it works
nice people, sometimes with lawyers, get together and figure out what's fair
So Hank in your last video you talked about copyright and intellectual property
and correctly pointed out that the measures currently before congress on this topic are a steaming hot slice of crazy
which is now apparently a vegetable
but that said, copyright is really complex
like obviously you're not violating my copyright if you post a quote from my book on your Tumblr
and obviously you are violating my copyright if you post my book on your Tumblr
but the question of where you draw that line is really complicated and ill-defined
side note: a lot of people will say that creative commons can bypass all of these problems
but I don't think so
I'm a big fan of creative commons and Hank you and I have both released a lot of stuff
from songs to zombie apocalypse novellas, via creative commons licenses
but I just don't think it's practical for everything
Okay so let me give you an example of the complexity of fair use and the kind of chilling effect it can have on discourse
In 2004 I was finishing a novel called Looking for Alaska
and the nice lawyers at penguin decided the character Alaska quotes too much of an Edna St Vincent Millay poem
The poem begins: Night falls fast
Today is in the past
Blown from the dark hill,
Hither to my door
Three flakes,
Then four arrive
then many more
they decided under fair use I could only quote two lines of the poem
and that if I wanted to quote more
I would have to pay Edna St Vincent Millay's estate
which I would've done except I didn't have any money
So Hank in the same situation today I would just pay
and use the quote and it would be fine
because now, thanks to Copyright, I've sold some books and I have enough money to pay for that kind of thing
So one of my big issues with copyright law is that currently it privileges  people like 2011 me
who have $500 or whatever to pay Edna St Vincent Millay's estate
and it punishes people like 2004 me who don't have that money
and the really terrifying thing to me about the legislation currently before congress
is that it would increase that inequality
YouTube and Google and Tumblr can afford lawyers to fight lawsuits from viacom
but I can't
meanwhile this legislation will do nothing to stop wholesale piracy
because it is already illegal
Hank, in the end it only made my book a little bit worse to lose those lines
and I'm gonna disagree with the alarmists
I suspect that if SOPA were to pass it would only make the internet a little bit worse
but the internet doesn't need to be worse
it needs to be better
and I don't think SOPA is pushing us in the right direction at all
So Hank, that's my take. And you can trust me, I'm a man bra
Nerdfighters lets continue the conversation in comments
Hank, I will see you on Wednesday!